let me ask you he said meaning what's
the meaning of this whole thing what's
the meaning of life you're the perfect
person to ask this question
I believe the meaning of life is for
human beings to grow in Soul that's why
we're here and you can do that in
infinite numbers of ways but you're
supposed to return your soul like more
burnished and beautiful
then you got it I mean it's gonna have
you know some Nicks and cuts
um
but that's what it means to deepen and
grow it and you do that you do that
um
more than anything else you do that by
learning how to love I mean that's the
principal way I think that you do it you
know it's interesting because uh for a
human
the relationship
um if you're a man of faith is with God
but it feels like love is so
richly part of human society that it's
not just love with of God it's love of
each other right yep there's no question
about the idea I mean
in Judaism that was actually the great
innovation of the monotheistic idea in
Pagan societies it was all about how you
treated the Gods
monotheism said no God cares how you
treat each other
so
it's in fact the mystics use the same
kind of
um word in Hebrew duveit which means
clinging that is used about Adam and Eve
uh about it says therefore a man will
leave his father and mother and devak
with his wife
and davach means cling so there is an
analogy there absolutely yeah kind of I
kind of think of human civilization is
that
um there's that movie March of the
Penguins and they're all huddling
together in a cold this is this is
fundamentally human is this is this
um just this Darkness all around us of
uncertainty of Cruelty of just we're
we're it's it seems like everything is
so fragile uh and we're just kind of all
huddling together for warmth yes and
that's all we got is each other
so uh we started with the the big
question of what has God ended with what
is meaning
uh Rabbi will be I've been a huge as
I've told you huge huge fan of this for
a long time it's such an honor to you I
am really interested so happy to be here
and thank you so much for the
conversation